MAYA BEN-ARI: Hello,
everyone, and welcome
to "Inclusive
Design and Testing,
Making Your App Accessible."
My name is Maya Ben-Ari.
I'm a product manager on
Android accessibility.
With me today is
Casey Burkhardt,
who is an engineer on
Google accessibility team,
and we'll also have Michal who
runs APPlicable Google Tel Aviv
program.
Michal will be
joining us by video.
We are very excited to have
you all in this session
today and thank
you all for coming.
Our agenda will start
with a brief overview
about accessibility,
then we'll tell you
more about the APPlicable
Google Tel Aviv program.
We'll dive into inclusive
design best practices
and we'll have a
section about testing.
So first, what is accessibility?
Accessibility is about
creating products
that are usable by everyone.
This include also users
with disabilities,
such as vision impairment
or motor impairment,
but I'd like to rephrase
this definition slightly
differently, and I would
say that accessibility
is about challenging
the assumptions we
make about our users.
For example, can the
user see the device?
Can he or she distinguishes
between color?
Can the user touch the device?
And can the user hear the sound
that the device is producing
and speak back to the device?
Now, this is not a small number
that we are talking about.
20% of the US population will
have some sort of a disability
during their lifetime.
But this is not all.
Challenging the
assumption we make
will benefit all users, as
some of the technologies that
were developed in the past, such
as speech recognition and work
prediction started as
technologies for users
with accessibility needs.
But this is not all.
We are all users with
accessibility needs sometimes.
This is called
situational disability.
For example, when
we drive our car,
we cannot look at our device.
When we are in a
noisy environment,
we cannot listen to the sound
that the device is producing
and we cannot speak
back to the device.
And when we carry heavy
bags from the supermarket,
we cannot use our hands
to interact with a device.
So we want to create
an inclusive experience
for all our users regardless
of what restriction they
might have.
Now, in the next
section, we are going
to tell you more about
APPlicable Google Tel Aviv
program.
So what is APPlicable?
APPlicable is the program
that helps startups to make
their app more accessible.
And APPlicable does so by
inviting developer and startups
to their campus to witness how
blind and motor-impaired user
are using their apps.
So this is a video that Michal
Waltner from Google Tel Aviv
just sent us.
Let's move to the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Ilana Benish
and I am 38 years-old.
I born blind.
I had many surgeries
and they have succeeded
to improve my sight in one eye.
Independency means access.
Many of the technologies
that available today are not
accessible and that's
why I came to APPlicable.
-My name is Michal.
I'm the program manager
of Campus Tel Aviv, which
is a Google space that is
dedicated to entrepreneurs
and startups needing help
in the local ecosystem
to create amazing startups.
I started thinking, how is it
possible that this huge market
is not being addressed?
Because if they knew that
with some easy steps,
they can actually make their app
accessible to this huge market,
I was sure that they bound
to do something about this.
So this is how the idea of this
program of APPlicable started.
-My name is Ariel Kedem.
I'm a mobile product
manager at Fiber.
Fiber is a marketplace
for creative professionals
who are helping people
productize and make money
from their talent.
Fiber is trying to
change how people work,
and allowing people with
disabilities to work with Fiber
is something big.
-Well, we started with visually
impaired and blind people.
Each table had a startup.
Mentors from the design
world, from the product world,
and developers sat
together with a person
with a visual
impairment and a person
who was blind to see how he's
actually using his own app.
-My name is Jonathan, Android
developer and evangelist
in Gett.
Gett is a leading platform
for on-demand services,
like Gett Taxi, or Gett Pizza,
or even Gett the Doctor.
I remember at the
beginning, there
was a woman who said,
ah, you're from Gett?
I'm not talking with you.
Like, you make my life awful.
When you make this difference
for them, first of all,
you feel proud.
Because, like, you've
really helped someone.
One of the really
small changes that we
did that had a huge
impact was that we
have-- when you open an app,
you have marketing pop-up right
straight on the screen and
it doesn't have any label.
So for the blind people,
it was, like, oh,
so we're showing a
regular map with a address
and Order a Taxi
button, and wasn't aware
that there, actually, that
marketing pop-up and they
can't click on anything
or using the TalkBack.
And by just verifying that if
your-- that TalkBack is turned
off, not showing this pop-up
is, like, huge difference,
because now these people are
able to order a taxi instead
of constantly clicking
on the marketing pop-up
and not understanding why
they can't order a taxi.
Actually, the input was that
she went out of the building
and she said, oh, now
I'm able to order a taxi.
-We actually did some
really small change.
We have a page of
categories within Fiber.
It was built like,
put a category
next to a category
in a very long page.
And when we did one of the
session, they just tell me,
just build them one in a row
and not one next to each other.
So we changed it.
We put it in the app home
page and just changed
dramatically how people
navigate the app.
Thinking about a
simple experience,
it just made me a
better product manager.
-But it's a really
small effort just
to change a little bit bytes
of code to add additional stuff
and you can make really a
huge difference for them,
for their daily routine.
-Tagging your components
on a specific page.
Giving an image
the right alt tag.
It's really something that
when you change how you think,
it's very simple.
Enable the accessible
view on your phone.
Try to use the phone as someone,
just for example, can't see.
This will affect everything
you do dramatically.
-Button 96, unlabeled.
Button 13, unlabeled.
Button 74, unlabeled.
Button.
Button 18, unlabeled.
Button 35, unlabeled.
Button.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-How was was it?
-A disaster.
No, really, a disaster.
-So after about half a year that
we dealt with visual impairment
and blindness, we went to the
second stage of the program
and addressed people
with motor disabilities.
So again, we opened
testing labs.
We brought the mentors.
We brought people
with disabilities.
We brought startups.
And we realized that
this is definitely
something that is so needed.
-Take your phone in one
hand and start to run.
Run.
Running and try to send
message during the running.
You will have a lot of mistakes.
And you need to erase and
retype, erase and retype.
And this is my life
when I'm using apps.
I'm Ohad.
I'm 39 years-old.
I'm working in Gett as
a senior QA engineer.
I have cerebral palsy, and the
effect of that you can see.
My speech is very-- I
have a difficult speech.
And my right hand
is not functional
and also both two legs
are not functional.
And I have only one hand.
And even in that hand I
have-- in three fingers
I have a spastic.
It's very difficult to touch--
to reach all the corners
with one finger.
My wildest dream is that
I will have the ability
to put each button in
the place that I want.
I know that the designers and
UI and UX wouldn't love that,
but it will make the app
more accessible for me
and for the many,
many other people.
This is my dream.
-To meet with them, to
tell them our needs,
it was very, very
important meetings.
-My message to all developers
will be, hey, guys,
you are there.
You're actually the one
that can have the power
to change, for a lot of
people, their entirely life.
-I think about this
amazing APPlicable session
in every screen, page, or button
that I'm adding to the app.
And make the app more
accessible, it's a must.
So now the ball
is in your hands.
-Accessible apps are
changing our lives every day
and will continue to change
everybody's life every day.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
MAYA BEN-ARI: So I'd like to
thank Michal from Campus Google
Tel Aviv APPlicable
program for sending us
this wonderful video.
From the video, we saw that
sometime small changes may have
big impact on people lives.
For example, as Jonathan
from Gett-- Jonathan
is here, by the way.
Just adding labeling
to the app that
was previously not accessible
made a huge difference.
And finally, and
then, like, suddenly,
a user who couldn't use the
app could now order a cab.
So in the next
section, we are going
to get into specific
suggestion on how
to create a more inclusive
experience for all users.
So first, what is
inclusive design?
Every product decision
that we make in our app
may include or exclude
certain types of users.
So what we want is to take
into this consideration
those people with
a different need
and to design our app which
is reachable and accessible
to the different users.
That all sounds good,
but how do we do that?
So the first thing
that you need to do
is to be familiar and try
the different accessibility
services.
This is what APPlicable
program is doing,
is you want to
understand the experience
of different users
with different needs.
So first, what is an
accessibility service?
An accessibility service is a
long-running privilege service
that can do one of two things.
One, it changes the way the
user interact with the design--
interact with a device.
Or second, it changes
the way that the content
is represented to the users.
Now, today we have four
different accessibility
services available
on the platform.
The first one is TalkBack.
TalkBack is targeted for blind
and visually impaired user.
And it's basically
a screen reader
that the user can interact
with using gesture
and the content is represented
through text to speech.
Now, let's take a
look at that one.
Let's switch to the demo.
So now I'm inside of Android
settings in Accessibility,
and I can go into TalkBack
and turn TalkBack on.
PHONE: TalkBack on.
MAYA BEN-ARI: I'll
go to home screen.
PHONE: Home screen 1 of 1.
Home screen 1 of 1.
MAYA BEN-ARI: So with
TalkBack, the user
has two ways to interact
with the device.
The first one is called
linear navigation.
So basically, for
whatever icon or element
that currently has
focus, the user
can use swipe gesture to
move between elements.
PHONE: Phone.
MAYA BEN-ARI: For example.
PHONE: Messenger.
Apps.
MAYA BEN-ARI: Now,
when the user wants
to activate a specific
element, he can basically
double-tap anywhere
on the screen
and the element that currently
has focus will open up.
PHONE: Apps lock.
MAYA BEN-ARI: So this
is linear navigation.
The second way for
a user to interact
is called explore by touch.
In this case, the user
will put one finger down,
and then he can navigate across
the screen, and every element
that gains focus, TalkBack
will read out loud.
Let's take a look.
PHONE: Better Bug.
Calculator.
Click.
Chrome.
Drive.
Gmail.
Clock.
MAYA BEN-ARI: Now,
when the user would
like to open that
element, again, he
can tap anywhere on the screen
and the element that has focus
will open up.
PHONE: Clock.
MAYA BEN-ARI: This is TalkBack.
The second service that we
have is called BrailleBack.
BrailleBack--
PHONE: Showing
items 1 to 2 of 2.
MAYA BEN-ARI: Thank
you, TalkBack.
[LAUGHTER]
The second service that we
have on the platform today
is called BrailleBack.
Now, with BrailleBack,
the user is
interacting with a
refreshable Braille
display such as this one.
In this case, the user have
this keyboard or the joystick
and he can interact similarly
to how the user interact
with TalkBack,
just in this case,
the content is going
to be represented
in Braille on
those Braille cells
with the dots
raising and lowering.
So this is BrailleBack.
The third service we
have on the platform
is called Switch Access.
Switch Access is targeted
for motor-impaired user
who have trouble interacting
with a touch screen.
In this case, the
user can connect
something which is called an
adaptive switch like this one.
In this switch-- this
switch has two buttons.
It can have more or less button.
In this one, the user will
set one of the button as next
and one of the button as select.
Then the interaction
with switch access
will be similar to the linear
navigation of TalkBack,
just in this case,
the user will interact
using the buttons
rather than gestures.
Let's go to the slides, please.
Now, the last service
is called Voice Access.
This is a service we
recently launched.
And the user can perform
low-level interaction
using his voice.
If you would like to
learn more about this one,
we have the access
and [INAUDIBLE]
sandbox just outside
of this room.
Now, note, those are
representative examples
of the capabilities
of accessibility APIs.
Every developer can develop
services similar this one,
but you can use those
one to actually test
how your app interacts with
accessibility services.
Now, if you would like to
focus on only two services,
please test with Switch
Access and TalkBack.
Why's that?
Because with Switch
Access, what you can test
is how accessibility
services interact
with your UI, which is
basically testing your input.
And with TalkBack, what
you are going to test
is how content is
represented to the user.
For example, whether
you have labeling,
so you will test the output.
So with Switch
Access and TalkBack,
you are going to test both
your input and output.
OK, so until now,
we are familiar
with the different
accessibility services.
Now, what you want to make
sure is that your application
works well with those.
And how do you do that?
You following Android
accessibility best practices.
In the next part of
the presentation,
we brought to you
couple of highlights
that we gather from
our testing data.
So these are our top
four common suggestion
based on testing data of how
to improve app accessibility.
We have content labeling,
touch target size, contrast,
and view attributes.
Now, note, this is not
a comprehensive list,
but these are small
changes that you
can do in your app that may
have a significant impact.
The first one is
content labeling.
Why do we need that?
This is for visually
impaired or blind user
who are relying on screen reader
to understand what's going on.
Specifically, screen readers
need the content description
to understand UI elements
without visible text.
This is what we saw in
the applicable video.
Button 86, unlabel.
Button 99, unlabel.
So what you want is to use
content description in your XML
layout to describe the element.
For editable UI element,
our recommdation
is slightly different.
In this case, use android:hint
or android:labelfor
for anything which is editable.
Now, the next big
question is, how do I
write my content labeling?
And our most important
recommendation
is make sure your
labeling make sense.
So these are a
couple of do or don't
with regarding to labeling.
For example, if you have
an account switcher,
how you should describe the
content, switch to a gmail
some kind of a demo
account at gmail.com.
What you don't want to do is
to add the content labeling,
such as account switcher, switch
to account mydemo@gmail.com.
So please be succinct
with your content labeling
while describing enough context.
The next one is if
you have a Close
button, what you want to provide
is the labeling such as Close.
You don't want to provide
the labeling for a Close
button, because in that case,
the screen reader might read it
as a Close button button.
So please don't include the type
or the state of the UI element.
Now, the last one--
my last example.
If you have a pencil on
top of an image button,
use content labeling such
as edit and not pencil.
So please describe the
action and not the image.
Now, our second recommendation
is about increasing touch
target size.
This will allow users
with mobility impairments
to interact with
actionable UI elements.
So what we'd like you to do
is to make your touch target
size big enough.
What is big enough?
We recommend using touchable
items larger than 48 x 48 dp.
Now, it doesn't mean
that the whole image
needs to be 48 x 48.
As you can see here with
the magnification glass,
in that one, the
image is only 24 x 24.
But we want that the touch area
which responds to user input
will be bigger than 48 x 48.
Now, you can extend the
touchable bound beyond the view
size using TouchDelegate.
So for the next example
and to talk about contrast,
I'd like to invite
Casey onto the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
CASEY BURKHARDT: Thanks, Maya.
My name is Casey Burkhardt.
I'm a software
engineer on Google's
accessibility engineering team.
Our third best practice
today is about contrast.
Ultimately, this comes down to
how well visually distinguished
your elements in your UI are.
This comes down to
the colors we choose
to represent content in our UI.
The way we measure
contrast is by looking
at the luminance,
the brightness,
of the colors used in the
foreground and background
of an individual UI element.
Having a high level of
contrast in our apps
is important for users
with visual impairments,
but also for people with light
sensitivity, like myself,
and we want to
ensure that we meet
a minimum level of
contrast between the colors
we choose for the foreground and
the background of our content.
Now, there are a bunch
of tools online that
will allow you to plug
in your color values
and obtain what we
call a contrast ratio.
This is simply a ratio of the
luminance of the foreground
to background.
There are a number
of tools online that
can be really helpful to
go and identify these,
and we'll actually
see one in just a bit.
So specifically,
what do we recommend?
For any use of
images or iconography
in your application, we
recommend a contrast ratio
of 4.5:1, meaning either the
foreground or the background
is going to be 4 and 1/2
times brighter than the other.
For text content,
our recommendation
varies based on
the size of text.
If your text is large-- that's
18 scale pixels or larger--
we recommend a ratio of 3:1.
For text any smaller than that,
we recommend the 4.5:1 ratio.
And on this slide,
we can actually
see a few examples of
primary color combinations
and how they stack up in
terms of contrast ratios.
So as we can see, white
and yellow on black,
and white and yellow on blue,
both meet the 4.5 ratio.
But note that white
or yellow on red
should only be used in
combination with large text.
We also see a few examples
of color combinations
that don't work well, such as
blue on black, red on blue,
or white on yellow.
These shouldn't be used in
combination with one another.
Our fourth and final best
practice for accessibility,
inclusive design,
is all around how
your application
represents its views
within the View hierarchy.
Android's accessibility
services will
use View attributes to determine
how to represent and navigate
content within your app.
Here we have an example
of a very simple demo
application with two buttons.
We're going to use Switch
Access, as an example,
to see how the
application is interacted
with with the
accessibility service.
So in this case, the
layout is very simple.
For button1, it's simply
a standard Android button
within a linear layout.
It is clickable by
default. So let's see
how Switch Access interacts
with this widget when
we try to click it.
Let's roll the clip.
So Switch Access focus is going
to move to the first button,
we'll hit Select, and we
see a little snack bar
at the bottom indicating that
the button's been clicked.
This is the exact behavior
we're looking for.
It's simple and
works as expected.
Now, we'll complicate
the example a little bit
for button2.
In this case, we'll add an
additional linear layout
and we'll mark it as
android:clickable equals true.
Now, this represents that
we have two clickable things
in our hierarchy, the button
and its parent linear layout.
This can actually create
some confusion and difficulty
when using this application
with Switch Access.
Let's try it, and roll the clip.
So we're going to
move focus to button2.
We're going to hit
Select, and we're actually
presented with a menu
where the user has
to choose do they want to select
the higher level clickable
item or the lower
level clickable item.
And this is confusing,
because the user
doesn't need to know the details
about our application's View
hierarchy.
So we force the user to memorize
that they need to click 1 or 2
within a particular application.
This is rather confusing,
but we can luckily
fix this pretty easily.
So the right fix here is
since this linear layout
is not actually clickable, we'll
remove the clickable attribute.
Alternatively, since
this layout really
isn't used for anything
else, we can just
remove the layout entirely.
View attributes can also affect
how screen readers navigate
content and present content to
users within your application.
Here we have an
example of a receipt.
We have information in
this UI that is associated.
We have a subtotal,
tax, and a grand total
that has a key
value relationship
with other views on the screen.
Since these values are
associated, what we'd really
want is this information to
be spoken as one logical unit
by the screen reader.
As you can see in
this example, we just
have a single relative layout
with two standard text cues.
Nothing is defined as focusable.
So each of these
text views is going
to be focused and
spoken independently
by the screen reader.
And this has the potential to
create a confusing experience,
because the screen
reader user may not
be able to associate this
information linearly.
So what do we do instead?
Luckily, the fix here
is pretty simple.
Anytime we have a layout that
groups associated information,
we simply set android:focusable
equals to true.
And we will see now
that the screen reader
focuses that content and speaks
it as one logical unit, which
is the behavior we want here.
So we've seen a
number of examples
of accessibility best practices,
what to do and what not to do,
but there's a lot more
than just these four.
You may find that throughout
your development process,
you run into unique
accessibility challenges.
So we encourage you
all to go and review
the material design best
practices for accessibility.
A link will be in the
spaces for this talk.
So now that we know
about Android's
accessibility services,
how to use them,
and we know about Android's
accessibility best practices,
let's talk about applying
them and integrating
this testing for
these best practices
into our development process.
And with that, let's
talk about testing.
Our recommended approach to
testing for accessibility
is manual testing.
As you've seen in the APPlicable
video, people, engineers,
startups are
learning exactly how
users with accessibility
needs are using their apps
through one-on-one interaction.
This is a great example of
how to do manual testing.
It is the most reliable way to
find the user experience pain
points within our apps.
So we recommend that
you go and learn
about each of Android's
accessibility services
and try them out in your app.
Now, there are some
challenges with this.
It takes a lot of time to
actually go through an app
with each of these
services and scaling
this across multiple
applications
can be a rather large endeavor.
Understanding the
user experience
takes a lot of time,
at least understanding
what is expected of each of
these accessibility services.
Also, just eyeballing an
application, looking at it,
it's sometimes
difficult to assess
some aspects of accessibility.
It's difficult to sometimes
say, oh yes, the contrast
is too low here or this
touch target is slightly
below the guideline.
So what we wanted
to do was build
a set of tools that could
make these tasks easier
for development teams.
So we've created the Android
accessibility testing
framework.
And this is a Java
Android library
that is intended to look
at Android UI constructs
and make assessments
for accessibility.
We'll make
recommendations for things
you can improve in
your application's UI
to make things a little
more accessible to people
who need it.
So this framework is integrated
with a number of other testing
tools that we're
going to discuss now.
The first is Espresso.
It's a UI testing
framework for Android.
And we've integrated with
Espresso and another framework,
Robolectric, for unit
testing, in a way that
allows you to use your
existing tests to leverage
coverage for accessibility.
So how does this work?
We have one class.
It's called
AccessibilityChecks, and it's
used between Espresso
and Robolectric
to enable accessibility
testing functionality
in your current tests.
So in Espresso, so I simply
call AccessibilityChecks.enable
within my test
classes setup method.
And in Robolectric, I simply
annotate my test class
with AccessibilityChecks.
Now, when I go ahead and run my
tests, we'll get some output.
And here's an example of that.
This is a Robolectric
test that I've
written for a test application.
And this test itself asserts
nothing about accessibility,
it simply asserts that clicking
a button performs some action.
Because I've annotated this test
class with AccessibilityChecks,
we get accessibility evaluation
behavior for free any time
Robolectric interacts
with one of our views.
So as our test
clicks on this view,
we actually run our
accessibility tests,
and we found that this view is
missing a spoken description
for a screen reader.
So this would be a good cue for
you to go look at your content
labeling, make sure you've
provided content descriptions
or appropriate labels.
So in this case, we actually
prevented an accessibility bug
from getting checked
into our app's codebase
by relying on accessibility
tests in our other test
frameworks.
Now, that's great for
engineers, but what
about other members of
product development teams,
app development teams?
Well, we wanted to build a
tool that leveraged the power
of Android's accessibility
test framework
for other project
contributors too.
So Google's recently shipped
Accessibility Scanner
at the end of March.
It's a tool for all members
of product development
teams, technical or
non-technical alike.
It allows for quick on-device
real time evaluations
of accessibility and
will present suggestions
for improving accessibility
within your app
very quickly and easily.
Let's actually take a look at
how Accessibility Scanner works
in practice.
Now let's switch to the demo.
OK, so here I have a device with
Accessibility Scanner installed
and enabled.
There's a floating
action button that
appears on top of every UI.
And I'll open up a test
application that we created,
which intentionally introduced
some accessibility issues.
To run an evaluation,
I'll simply
tap on the Scanner button.
And in just a few
seconds, we'll see
an overlay showing us
which areas of our UI
may need some work.
Let's take a look at a
few suggestions here.
So it looks like this item
is missing a description
for a screen reader.
We should go back and look
at the content description
we may have missed here.
It looks like we have a
small touch target here.
We can even get the specifics
about the current size.
And it looks like we may
have some low contrast text.
It looks like we only have
a contrast ratio of 1.9
here, so we'll want to fix that.
Accessibility Scanner
makes it easy to look
at all the issues within
your application's UI,
and even take those
issues and share them
with my development team.
Now, we can go and
get these bugs fixed.
We get a simple report
with a screenshot
and we can send that off.
Now that we can go
and fix our issues,
let's see how Accessibility
Scanner performs on a UI
where we've taken its
suggestions into account.
Looks like we're in good shape.
That's Accessibility Scanner.
[APPLAUSE]
A few final words on
automated testing.
Think of these automated
testing tools as a way
to get first pass evaluations
of your apps for accessibility.
We will not be able to find
every accessibility issue
that an app may
have and we won't
be able to fully understand
what a user experience is
for various users with
accessibility needs.
So we do really
advocate manual testing
with Android's
accessibility services
to get that full picture.
Finally, our testing
tools are only
as good as your use of
them or the coverage
of your other tests.
In Robolectric and
Espresso, you're
only going to be able
to evaluate controls
that you interact with.
So you want to make sure that
your test coverage is good
if you expect good coverage
from the accessibility automated
tools.
Similarly, Accessibility
Scanner can only
evaluate the things that
it sees on the screen
in that present time.
You may need to do separate
evaluations for portrait
versus landscape currently.
So just a few caveats.
These tools are here to
help you identify things
quickly and prevent bugs
from being checked in,
but always use manual testing
approaches to validate
your user experience.
And with that, I'd like to hand
it back to Maya to wrap up.
[APPLAUSE]
MAYA BEN-ARI: Thank you,
Casey, for the lively demo--
lovely demo.
So you saw today inclusive
design can create a better
experience for everyone.
And we recommend following
these three [INAUDIBLE].
First, get familiar
with the experience
for users with
accessibility needs
by trying out
accessibility services.
Specifically, please try out
TalkBack and Switch Access.
Second, follow accessibility
best practices.
In the next slide, we are going
to present a couple of links.
We'll also share those
links on this talk spaces.
And finally, develop and test
with accessibility in mind.
And we provided today some
tools, such as Android testing
frameworks with
Robolectric and Espresso,
and Accessibility
Scanner, to try those out.
Now, final word.
The sooner you consider
accessibility users,
their needs, the better
you can address those needs
and design a better
experience in your app
to include all type of users.
So these are a few links.
This is what's next.
Waiting for people
to take a pictures.
OK?
All good?
One more.
And I'd like to thank
Casey and thank Michal
for creating this session.
CASEY BURKHARDT:
Thank you very much.
MAYA BEN-ARI: Thank
you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]